alarm im saarland in saarbrücken im
stadtteil klarenthal ist ein
polizeibeamter durch schüsse verletzt
worden demnach soll ein mann ein
waffenbesitzer aus dem fenster
geschossen haben der 67-jährige sollte
wohl kontrolliert werden ja bereits um 8
41 berichtet die polizei auf twitter von
einem verletzten polizisten nach einem
einsatz es folgen warnungen für die
bevölkerung die menschen sollen in ihren
häusern und von den fenstern weg bleiben
und immer wieder der hinweis achtung das
gebiet ist weiträumig abgesperrt auch
das sek ist vor ort
aktuell ist der einsatz noch in der
weiteren planung die person hat sich in
seiner wohnung verbarrikadiert
wir planen jetzt die weiteren maßnahmen
wie wir mit der person in kontakt treten
können
ja und auch bild reporter steffen meyer
beobachtet für uns die lage vor ort was
kannst du uns berichten wie es die
aktuelle situation
ja hallo guten morgen nach berlin also
der einsatz ist noch am laufen sind etwa
60 70 beamte teilweise maskiert und mit
schutzwesten unterwegs eben kurz mal
kurz dramatisch ist sind ungefähr acht
bis zehn schüsse noch mal gefallen die
polizei hat auch gerade noch getwittert
dass der mann noch aus den aus dem
fenster schießen soll aus dem haus in
dem er sich befindet
das haus ist etwa 100 meter hinter uns
luftlinie und ist es so ein bisschen
mehr weiß man schon über ihn er soll
jäger sein der mann der 67-jährige und
er soll ungefähr 25 waffen besitzen und
die wollte heute die waffenbehörde
zusammen mit der polizei
in beschlag nehmen und dann soll es zu
diesem schusswechsel und beziehungsweise
zu den schüssen gekommen sein er soll
aus dem fenster auf die beamten
geschossen haben ein beamter wurde
verletzt eben gerade wurde uns gesagt er
ist außer lebensgefahr in einer klinik
dass es also schon mal die gute
nachricht
du konntest du auch mit augenzeugen
sprechen was sagen sie was haben sie
mitbekommen genau ich habe den herrn
rollier getroffen
der holt ist mit seiner firma tätig
schräg gegenüber des hauses waren
mitarbeiter von ihm gerade am arbeiten
als die schüsse gefallen sind dann haben
sie ihn angerufen und die ging es dann
weiter herum ja die haben nicht
informiert heute morgen dass an unserer
baustelle schüsse gefallen sind und dass
es sich in den keller zurückgezogen
haben habe ich mich auf dem weg gemacht
hat hierher bin aber nicht
weitergekommen halt auch nur bis zur
absperrung als ich ankam habe ich auch
wieder vier schüsse gehört die kollegen
sie haben auch immer wieder telefon kann
kann auch zu denen
wie ist es bei gespannt und nervös
mittlerweile es hat sich etwas gelegt
aber natürlich natürlich angespannt wo
befinden sie sich gerade die beiden
die haben die türen fenster haben halt
als die schüsse gefallen sind die beiden
auch eben was gesagt ob sie den mann
gesehen haben gesagt sie haben gesehen
dass jemand aus dem fenster schießen und
dann sind sie halt um der politik bei
halt aufgefordert gut sieht ja und genau
diese waren und die kommt auch immer
wieder von der polizei aus über twitter
dass man sich eben von fenstern fern
halten soll und dass die gefahr auch
noch nicht vorbei ist haben wir gesehen
die polizei hat zahlreiche fahrzeuge in
stellung gebracht und ja bereitet
offensichtlich ein zugriff
man aus dem fenster geschossen hat und
dabei einen